PHILIP LAUGHLIN: Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
And I'm happy to say we did not
overlap at all in our content.
We're safe.
First of all I'd just
like to start off
by thanking Amy Brand, the
former Cognitive Science
Editor at MIT Press for inviting
me to speak at the Harvard Club
today.
I'm confident this will be
the only time in my life
that someone asks me to speak
at an Ivy League institution,
so I'm particularly grateful
that today's proceedings are
being videotaped and
posted on the web.
I'm looking forward to sending
URL to my incredulous friends.
In addition to giving me my
15 minutes of internet fame,
I'm happy to be here
because preparing this talk
was an educational
experience for me.
I have to confess
that although I've
been in my current position
for about 15 months,
I had never even seen, let alone
read the MIT Press submission
guidelines for book proposals
until Amy had sent them
to me about three days ago.
It turns out it's an extremely
useful document, definitely
more thorough and
professional than what
I have been giving authors, so
I strongly encourage everyone
here to refer to it when you
begin approaching publishers.
I think the advice contained in
it is universal enough that you
could follow these
guidelines for just about
any academic publisher,
not just MIT Press.
As useful as these proposal
guidelines are though,
they don't give you a
sense of the process
that I go through when trying
to decide what to publish.
It's sort of the difference
between reading a recipe
and cooking a meal, so I'd like
to supplement these guidelines
you have with some
background information
that you might find useful.
The first point that
I'd like to emphasize
to any aspiring
author is one that I'm
sure that we can
all sympathize with.
And that is, yours
is not the only email
that I received today.
Like most of you, I'm
drowning in e-mail.
I receive about 1,000
work-related emails
every month, and the
vast majority of them
are about dozens
of book projects
that are already under contract
and being written, recently
completed and need to go into
production, and currently
in production and need to be
ready for the next catalog
season.
And at any given
time, some percentage
of these projects, hopefully
a small percentage,
are in crisis mode.
Sometimes I'm involved in a very
delicate contract negotiation
with some big name author.
Sometimes a manuscript has
to be rushed into production
immediately to meet
some important deadline.
And sometimes an author is
irate about a copy editing,
typesetting, or a
cover design job.
That one doesn't
happen too often,
but it does happen
occasionally, it
and needs to be
addressed quickly.
So, a significant chunk
of my attention and energy
is already
monopolized by authors
who submitted book proposals to
me at least a year or two ago.
I don't say this to discourage
anyone from contacting me.
But I do want to make it
clear that, on a typical day
I'm not just sitting on my hands
hoping that someone sends me
a book proposal to look at.
I usually have a pretty
full plate already.
The second point that
I'd like to emphasize
is I already received far
more book proposals than I
could ever hope to publish.
Buried somewhere in
those 1,000 work emails
I received every month,
are about 20 to 30 queries
from potential authors who
are interested in seeing
their books published
by MIT Press.
So during any calendar year,
I'm likely to receive somewhere
in the neighborhood of 250 to
350 book proposal submissions.
Essentially what this
means is that, even
if I apply the most rigorous
standards for acceptance
and rejected 90%
of what I received,
I would still have enough book
projects to meet my signing
goals and to keep MIT'S
production department busy.
And in case you're wondering,
an acquisitions editor
should be publishing between
20 and 40 new books per year,
depending on what
field you work in.
So I'd like to
emphasize that no matter
who you are, or where
you got your PhD,
or how good your ideas are,
if you submit something
to me at MIT Press,
there's a very good chance
that you will receive
a polite rejection
letter from my assistant.
Please don't take it personally.
The problem isn't
necessarily with you,
the problem is really the
system that we all operate in.
I believe academics refer
to it as a social dilemma.
This embarrassment of riches
that I sift through every month
definitely has an influence
in how I respond to authors
and their book proposals.
So a third point I'd
like to emphasize today
is, there are entire catalogs--
or entire categories of books
that I frequently
reject out of hand.
For example, English
language translations.
For whatever
reason, whether it's
the subject areas I've
worked in or the publishers
I've worked at, English
language translations
don't seem to do very well.
And when I say work
very well, I am
speaking in the crudest
possible way about copies sold
and revenue generated.
I wouldn't go so far as
to say that I would never
publish a book
translated into English
from a foreign language,
but it's pretty unlikely
that I'll be interested in them.
Anthologies of previously
published material
is another category I'm wary of.
MIT Press used to publish
anthologies very successfully
in the 1980s and 1990s.
Many of those anthologies
are still in print
and continue to sell
steadily, but we've
seen a pretty dramatic decline
in the sales of new anthologies
over the past decade.
So I'm not quite so eager to
publish in this book category
anymore.
In philosophy, the
edited conference volume
is very difficult
sell these days,
and I've passed on quite a
few of them in the past year.
And finally, the humble
festschrift, the edited book
in honor of an
esteemed professor,
is something that
we'll do occasionally,
if the right people are
involved and it fits our list,
but for the most part, I try
not to make a habit of it.
I realize I'm starting to sound
like a broken record here,
but without wishing to be
negative or discouraging,
I would also include the
revised doctoral dissertation
on this list.
I don't think there's any
publisher anywhere in the world
that is currently plotting to
corner the market on revised
doctoral dissertations.
I'm not sure exactly
how many dissertations
are written in
the US every year,
but I'm pretty confident that
only a tiny percentage of them
are worth publishing.
And the ones that are
worth publishing, generally
have very modest
sales potentials.
And by modest, I mean
a few hundred copies,
so the potential return on
investment is pretty low.
To put it in stark,
realistic terms,
even if your
revised dissertation
merits publication,
we're still kind
of doing you a favor
by publishing it,
not the other way around.
However, I will confess
that I've recently broken
my own self-imposed rule in
four of the five categories
that I've just listed.
Within the past
year I've signed up
an anthology of previously
published material,
and within the past
month alone, I've
signed up an edited conference
volume by a philosopher,
a festschrift for a
philosopher, and a revised
doctoral dissertation
from a philosopher.
Furthermore, it's quite possible
that in the spring of next year
I'll sign up another revised
doctoral dissertation
from a political theorist.
So it is possible to get a
book published by a respected
University Press,
even if it falls
into one of these less
desirable categories.
What did these authors
do to beat the odds?
I'll focus on the two
doctoral dissertations
since that's the purpose
of today's gathering.
In the first example,
the philosopher
who I've already signed up
did something very simple,
he shamelessly used
his connections.
He became friendly with
a series editor of ours
and asked her for help
in crafting his proposal
and submitting it to us.
This was a very clever
strategy because, if I didn't
want the book, I would have
to reject two people, not just
one.
And the second person would
have to be a senior faculty
member who had previously
published a book with us
and is a pipeline for
future book projects.
So even if I really wanted
to reject this project,
I would have been
forced to come up
with a very compelling reason
to do so and communicate
that in a very delicate way.
And the second example,
the political theorist
who has not yet signed up.
I had actually approached
her last spring
to review a manuscript for me,
which she did a great job on,
by the way.
A couple of months
later, she contacted me
and asked if I was
interested in reviewing
her award-winning dissertation,
and in seeing if it would
be of interest to MIT Press.
The fact that this
person had written
a very constructive review
for me in a timely manner
put her in a positive
light already,
so I was a bit more
receptive to her proposal
than perhaps I would
have been otherwise.
But what really got me
interested in the project
was that it had a unique
interdisciplinary thesis
that I had not seen
anywhere else-- attempting
to merge empirical psychology
with political theory.
Plus she clearly knew the
MIT backlist very well,
and could articulate
how her book would
fit into our overall
publishing strategy.
So she had clearly
done her homework
and presented
herself in a way that
made me take her seriously.
In both of these
instances the authors
had a tentative
connection to the press
that they were able
to exploit-- one
through a series editor,
one by acting as a reviewer.
Because of these connections,
I probably gave these authors
a little bit more of my time
and attention than they normally
would have.
And by a little more
of my time I mean,
gave their emails
a couple of minutes
rather than a couple of seconds.
Of course, if the proposals
they had submitted to me
had been poorly conceived
or uninteresting,
the conversation probably
would have stopped there.
But the fact that they were also
able to deliver that they were
able to deliver
well-crafted proposals that
were able to withstand
the peer review process
was what really sealed the deal.
But what if you don't have
an in with the publisher?
What can you do to
improve your chances
of being taken seriously?
The first thing I would
suggest any aspiring author
is do your homework.
And I've always
wanted to say that
to a roomful of professors,
do your homework.
Don't just start sending queries
out to any random publisher.
Spend 30 or 40 minutes on Amazon
looking for the three or four
most relevant publishers for
your work and focus on them.
By relevant publishers,
I mean publishers
that consistently produce
books on your subject area
to this day.
If the last book that
a publisher produced
on a particular topic
was over 10 years ago,
that's usually a sign that
they pulled out of that area
and aren't looking
for new projects.
Maybe 10, 15, 20
years ago one could
be acceptably ignorant
on this point,
but today there's
really no excuse
for the author who
sends his manuscript
on pre-socratic philosophy to
the MIT Press, which actually
happened to me recently.
Second, when making an initial
approach to a publisher,
keep it brief.
Really, I only need
three or four sentences
to determine whether or not I'm
interested in seeing something,
not three or four paragraphs,
not three or four pages,
certainly not three
or four chapters.
Three or four
sentences are fine.
If I want to see more
material from you,
I'm perfectly capable
of asking for it.
What you want to avoid
at all costs is this,
is my lone, low tech visual aid.
This is an actual
book proposal that
was sent to me about a
month ago from an author.
The very first email
that he sent me.
And as you can see
it is six pages
of single-spaced material,
full of all the jargon
that Elizabeth was railing
against a few moments ago.
Plus another 20
pages in attachments.
Unless this is a
love letter written
to me by Gisele Bundchen,
I'm not going to read this.
I think I spent about
30 seconds perusing it,
and then I forwarded it to
my assistant to. reject.
So, don't be this guy.
Really, there's
absolutely no need
to send that much material
in an initial email.
Third, if I do respond
to your initial query
and ask to see
more material, you
will really help your case
if the material you submit
follows APA style or
Chicago Manual Style.
If I have to make formatting
changes to read what I've sent,
that's not a good
starting position for you.
There is absolutely nothing
wrong with double-spaced,
New York Times Roman
font at 12 points.
And it will greatly
increase the likelihood
that I will spend a few
minutes, rather than
a few seconds on your project.
This seems like a very
simple thing to do,
but you'd be surprised how
many authors get tripped up
on this small detail.
Fourth, if you think
your submission is--
if I think your submission
is interesting and worth
considering, I'll send
it out to three or four
external reviewers to look at.
When choosing a
reviewer, I'm not
looking for your arch
nemesis or someone who
wants to make your
life miserable,
but it just so happens
that reviewers can be harsh
and a little nasty sometimes.
So when you respond
to reviewer reports,
it's best to stay
above the fray.
Don't get petty and
personal in your response.
Try to separate the
substantive criticisms
from the personal ones,
and respond to those.
When I present projects at are
publishing committee meetings,
my colleagues definitely
reward mature adult behavior.
So, an author who responds
to reviewer feedback
in a constructive way,
not a defensive way,
is more likely to be approved.
And finally, after all this,
if we do get to the stage
where I send you a contract
for your revised dissertation,
I do have one piece of advice
for you on negotiating--
don't do it.
Standard contracts don't
vary much from publisher
to publisher.
And unless there is language
in the contract about waiving
constitutional rights or
giving up a firstborn child,
just sign it and send it back.
Getting your first book
published by a reputable press
is more important than haggling
over electronic royalties.
Save it for contract number two.
Thanks for listening.
[CLAPPING]